we cannot become numb to violent
attacks on our democracy we can't do it
which is why we're down to seven weeks
but we must continue to cover
the things that donald trump is saying
and doing that are completely
anti-democratic now i know we've talked
before
we've become accustomed to this to some
degree
this has been normalized to some degree
because we've been dealing with it for
four years but we
have to resist the tendency
to believe what's going on is even
remotely normal
this morning donald trump tweeted that a
governor overturned the results of the
election
which trump lost and then cancel i
guess trump is referring to the upcoming
senate runoffs
it is not 100 clear what trump is
demanding here
but what we can tell for sure is that
it's completely corrosive
and destructive to our democratic
institutions this morning in response to
a tweet about once again
dominion voting systems donald trump
tweeted quote
do something brian kemp you allowed your
state
to be scammed you must check signatures
and count signed envelopes against
ballots
then call off election it won't be
needed
we will all win so what i believe donald
trump is saying here is
maneuver the count of signatures
and envelopes which will lead to
trump winning georgia and i guess he
means
it will also lead to david perdue and
kelly loffler
both winning their senate races which
now are going to lead to runoffs
trump believes i guess if the votes are
counted the way
he wants them counted trump wins georgia
loffler wins georgia and purdue wins
georgia
and the runoffs are no longer needed
this is absolutely and totally insane
moments earlier
donald trump tweeted again incorrectly
and without evidence that quote
we won michigan by a lot he of course
did not win michigan he lost michigan to
joe biden
by about 150 000 votes he's just making
things up
seven minutes prior to that donald trump
tweeted quote
fake election results in nevada also
this is absolutely outrageous we can't
just
ignore it we have to actually resist
that this is normal in our minds for the
next seven weeks we've got to work hard
i
i i i'm you know as aware as i am of it
we have to still work hard it's like
pushing a boulder up a hill like
sisyphus to prevent the normalization of
this
insanity we've become somewhat numb
to the reality that this is what the u.s
president does every day but we really
should not become numb to it for our own
sake
at some point is this sedition
look at the definition sedition is
conduct or
speech inciting people to rebel against
the authority of a state
when donald trump asks brian kemp to
overturn disregard not
count certain that ballots specifically
to overturn the will of the people and
change the election results
at what point do we have to call it what
it is i'm not calling it treason but
looking at the definition of sedition
is this not seditious behavior to some
degree
there will never be repercussions he has
seven weeks left and then he's going to
go
there will not be repercussions but we
can't allow this to be mistaken for
anything
other than what it is and the the the
casual way
in which so many people now are just
writing all of this office
and trump's tweeting again the country
has never seen anything like this before
and we can't depart from this era
with anything other than the full
understanding that this is outrageous
there is nothing normal about it
and trump's press secretary is
participating in it and i want to talk
about that next
i want to let you know that our sponsor
vincero watches is having a massive
holiday sale on all of their products
right now and you can take advantage of
it by going to davidpakman.com
watch a brand new high quality
wristwatch really is the perfect way
to add something fresh to your style
whether it's for you
or a gift for someone else vincero is a
brand that has a serious dedication to
the craft of watchmaking which is really
evident when you look closely at their
watches
i wear vincero watches myself lately
i've been wearing one from their icon
automatic collection it's the mesh matte
black watch and i love the sleek
minimalist design
their watches are actually sold at a
fair price their mission has always been
to make a wristwatch from high-end
materials but one that
everyday people can afford and that's
why they have over
25 000 five-star reviews
because you won't find a better made
watch for
this great of a price anywhere else you
can get
big holiday discounts on all of their
products right now
and free shipping when you go to
davidpakman.com
watch i've put the link right underneath
this video